what you incentivize you get more of
that's the bottom line yeah what are you
incentivizing and you know I think about
like Thomas Soul said the black family
survived centuries of slavery and Jim
Crow but they could not survive the
liberal welfare state yeah it is the
liberal welfare state that destroyed the
black family at the turn of the century
in the 1900s black women outm married
white women and so this is not a problem
with black people are not able to form
families it's that the government helped
them so much that they have destroyed
the black family to the point where 71%
of kids who are born to black mothers
don't have a married father in the home